[Applause]
down the stretch here for los angeles
kawhi leonard has been on the bench
we've got 131 to go
in the fourth clippers lead at 114 to
103.
the phoenix suns have already advanced
to the western conference finals
this is game four of the western
conference semis with utah leading the
series two games to one
the clippers
have been in control throughout the
night the jazz have put some pressure on
la here in the fourth
paul george 31 points
matching kawhi leonard but there will be
a lot of talk
yeah in regards to leonard and his
status
[Music]
it appeared to be a right knee issue for
leonard
and before i let you go you know we saw
you collide with joe ingles there you
seemed like you were in a little bit of
pain
you sat not long after that any concerns
with that
right leg what happened there no it'll
be good thanks
you guys all right rebecca thank you
kawhi leonard gets to the point
and he does not want this to be a topic
of concern he just wants to go about his
business and the clippers did exactly
that
tonight final score 118
to 104 the clippers over the jazz for
greg anthony rebecca harlow the rest of
our nba on tnt crew
i and eagles sing so long from la coming
up next inside the nba presented by
kia you've been watching the nba
playoffs on
tnt this series tied at two and two as
we set it to atlanta
and ernie johnson